[GRANT] What's up guys welcome back today is an
exciting day because today is the day we
get to test out our nitro cotton. Now in
yesterday's video we took some extremely
dangerous acids and use them to turn
ordinary cotton balls into nitro cotton.
What exactly is nitro cotton? Well
you're about to find out. Now these here are
the cotton balls that we worked with
yesterday and I've let them sit
overnight so they're about as dry as we
can get them, which is good because I
don't think nitro cotton works very
well if it's wet. And now if we compare
them to one of our original cotton balls
you can see they're a little bit smaller
and they take on kind of a yellowish
tinge other than that it just feels like a
cotton ball that got a little bit too
wet and then dried out overnight
now you remember yesterday we weighed
each of our cotton balls individually
and I'm curious to know today now that
they've been nitrated if there's any
difference in weight. All right let's
start a cotton ball number one this was
0.55 grams originally and now we're
showing 0.80 grams it's kind of like fluctuating
at 0.5 I wonder if that's because
there's still a bit of moisture in it or
if it's actually changed weight
okay so I just reweighed all of the
cotton balls here and it seems that in
almost every case the cotton ball weighs
about 0.3 grams more than it did
yesterday and I'm not sure if that's
still because there's a little bit of
moisture in here that's waiting to
evaporate off or if the physical
properties of the cotton ball itself has
changed but in almost every case the
cotton ball has increased in weight by
0.3 grams interesting now this is the
fun part the moment we've all been
waiting for because now we get to burn
it now before we start burning our nitro
cotton let's start off burning one
regular cotton ball just so we have a
standard to measure it against now to
light this thing off we could just use
the flame from a BBQ igniter but that's
a little bit too easy so to switch
things up a little bit let's try using
some sparks from a ferrocerium rod and
hacksaw blade there we go we have
ignition the cotton ball ignites look at
the way it burns the cotton shrinks the
ball turns black as it leaves behind the
carbon residue you can see we got a good
25 to 30 seconds of burn time there with
regular cotton ball without flame right
there looks cool you need to see the
heat rising from the charcoal ash we're
left with now is basically black ash and
bring residue and that's got a lot of
smoke coming off it look at all the
smoke here with all the smoke
so you can see that gives about 25 to 30
seconds of burn time there's quite a bit
of smoke and the cotton ball doesn't
completely burn unless you move it
around and expose it to the oxygen so
now let's see how a regular cotton ball
compares to Nitro cotton so this is test
number one it's the first cotton ball we
soaked in acid yesterday so
theoretically it should be the most
volatile here it is boom there it goes
man okay so do you see the difference in
the burn time there the flash cotton
actually flash it went up in a huge ball
fire and if you look down here at the
res view there's really not much Ash
left over this is the original cotton
ball that's at your burning for about
two minutes before it finally died down
to this ash and there's still quite a
bit of residue our flash cotton you can
see almost everything is gone so cotton
ball one with the success and went up
very very quickly even though it was
still in cotton ball form if we would
have stretched those fibers out we could
get them go off even faster watch this
so we don't have to burn the whole
cotton ball at once we can actually
unroll it and give ourselves more
material to work with like so what's
really interesting is it still looks
like cotton it's still very fluffy it
still acts like cotton it's got a
slightly yellowish tinge to it try
ripping off a small piece of fiber like
this and touch it gently with a flame
and see just how quickly it goes off
gone in a flash that's why I love this
stuff it burns so quickly it disappears
before it even has a chance to at the
table it's why they call it flash cotton
folks flash paper and flash cotton is
the kind of stuff magicians using their
shows because it burns so quickly
it's very dramatic it doesn't leave any
smoke or any ashy residue and guys if
you flake off little pieces of your
cotton ball like this you can actually
stretch one cotton ball to go an
extremely long way
so we have it to tests down to full
successes now the purpose of this
experiment today is really to see how
many cotton balls we were able to
nitrate with 80 milliliters of nitric
acid we took eight cotton balls soaked
them each individually for five minutes
and my question is at what point is the
nitration start wearing off so this may
seem like a bit of a waste but what
we're going to do now is burn through
each of our cotton balls individually
until we find the point where our flash
cotton
stops flashing
bada-boom
whoa someone explosive
very volatile cotton ball number six
a little bit slower a little bit slower
and there's a little bit more ashy
residue there number seven
still a good burn but that was a lot
slower and you can see there's a lot
more after as well down to our last
cotton ball this is number eight and
it's even got a nice little fuse ticking
at the top for us
putting off a lot of interesting smoke
there look at that it's turning yellow
that's the Tsar is bringing extremely
slowly
lots of ash it didn't ignite at all it
just kind of fizzled down released a lot
of yellow smoke and turned into this
black ash which kind of has the smell of
sulfuric acid they left behind this tar
looking stuff as well
crispy black ash and a greasy tar
residue so interesting guys so out of 8
cotton balls the first five of them went
off perfectly very very quickly it
wasn't until the 6th cotton ball that we
noticed a little bit of black ash
residue a little bit more than normal
the seventh burn was a little bit slower
and the eighth ball didn't even burn at
all I just released a ton of yellow
smoke and melt it down into this black
ball of ash so I think based on our
experiment here today we can safely
conclude that 80 milliliters of nitric
acid will fully nitrate between 5 to 6
cotton balls now we can actually look at
the weights of our cotton balls and
figure out exactly how much cotton that
was so just looking at our numbers here
it looks like the first 5 to 6 cotton
balls comes out between about 3 grams to
3.25 grams so my best guess based on
this experiment is that 80 milliliters
of nitric acid will successfully nitrate
around 3 grams of cotton and don't
forget we nitrated a tampon as well
which is 2.4 grams so theoretically we
should be able to get this to work now
our little cotton tampon has a whole
heck of a lot of cotton in it so we
could actually stretch it out to last
quite a while but I'm thinking let's
just light off this little strip here
and if it works let's light off the
whole thing just because we can
beauteous like magic all right so that
worked no problem at all so let's go
ahead and fluff this tampon out a bit
and set it ablaze we go beautiful all
right here we go
flash tampon in three two one dang that
was a wicked fireball and it just went
up in my face and it was in an instant
like less than a second that entire
tampon was completely burned so we did
it the world's first pyrotechnic tampon
Cowabunga dude yeah and look at this
there's hardly any ash at all we've got
like little tiny bits of black fiber but
the rest of it is completely gone and no
smoke did you see there was no smoke in
that just a huge flash of fire in fact
that was quite a bit higher than I was
expecting it would right up into my face
and look there's hardly any ash residue
at all if you look down here it's just a
little bit of black matter but for the
most part that tampon is gone in its
entirety so that was really cool guys
and now based on these results I think
we can reach some conclusions from our
experiments here today we start off in
yesterday's video taking regular cotton
balls and soaking them in the solution
of nitric and sulfuric acid we rinse the
acid off soaked it in baking soda water
and then rinse it again and let them dry
overnight to produce a batch of flash
cotton the purpose of today's experiment
was to test those cotton balls to
identify where the nitration started
dropping off and based on our results we
found that happened right around cotton
ball number six now because we use 80
milliliters of nitric acid to brew six
cotton balls that went up in a flash we
determined that one milliliter of nitric
acid nitrates about point zero four
grams of cotton because our cotton balls
work so well just for fun we went ahead
and nitrated a cotton feminine hygiene
product to produce the world's first
pyrotechnic tampon so there we have it
guys we now know how to use nitric and
sulfuric acids to produce flash cotton
whoa thanks for joining me for this
experiment I'll be looking for you the
next one talk to you then all right here
we go shower of sparks in three two one
and I missed one two three four five six
seven eight
[MUSIC]